well sasha president donald trump landed
here at mccarran
in just the last hour you can still see
air force one
here behind me the president and his
team saying nevada is a big priority for
them in this election
with a campaign rally set for tomorrow
in carson city
this as early voting begins across the
state and with election day just over
two weeks away
now here is video of president trump
exiting air force one
and walking toward his motorcade the
president was last in nevada in
september
at a campaign rally in henderson there
was some controversy surrounding that
event because it was indoors
and few supporters were wearing masks we
spoke to the trump reelection campaign
communications director who says the
president's rally in carson city
tomorrow will be outdoors he also says
masks are given to everyone
president trump is expected to continue
touting his achievements
in the white house focusing as he
usually does on the economy
the trump team saying the president will
restore the economy
to pre-pandemic levels the president
is making clear and the people of nevada
know this president trump built the
world's best economy one time and he's
already doing it again
joe biden has been an economic disaster
throughout the course of his five
decades as a failed washington
politician
the nevada state democratic party
released a statement in response to
trump's visit
saying in part quote trump's desperate
attempts to erase his failed record
won't fool nevadans during this pandemic
and throughout his presidency
trump has chosen to prioritize his
wealthy well-connected friends over
hard-working nevadans again president
trump landed here in las vegas not too
long ago
we are hearing some reports that he'll
attend a church service
in town before heading to his rally in
carson city tomorrow
reporting live from mccarran
international airport tonight orc omana
8 news now